for months dozens of basketball courts
across southern nevada have stood
empty due to covet 19 restrictions
that's right well this week governor
steve sisalek signed a directive
allowing closer full contact sports to
begin again
allowing rims to be put back up now
reporter kate houston joins us live from
craig ranch regional park in north las
vegas with more hey kate
hey yes you know players have been
streaming into the park all afternoon
excited
to see these rims back up now as you can
see behind me here
the court back up and running packed
with some pickup basketball
providing some fun and relief to players
across the valley
starting early crews went to courts
across the valley reinstalling
rims the 35 hoops at craig ranch
regional park are now back
up much to the excitement of those who
live nearby
i was laughing i had to take a picture
so i could send it to the boyfriend
because he's just as anxious for the
hoops to go back up i feel
good i feel you know i feel great and i
appreciate it you know i've been waiting
for this day
terry stevens plays basketball five days
a week and was looking forward to
bringing his son back on the court
happy you guys he got the ball and the
rams back
so i get my exercise up and stay keeping
up with him
clark county started working on its 100
outdoor courts with the hopes of
finishing by thursday night
summerlin says it will take a few days
to get all of the hoops up
with henderson planning to reinstall all
the rims by early next week
many are excited to have another reason
to get out of the house
every time we drive through the park
they're just like uh can't wait for the
hoops when the hoops going back up
so they just been in the house playing
video games and youtube
you play with friends more and hang out
you get inside for way too long
now local leaders are asking everyone to
play safely
saying the ball is in your court
excitement
with a little bit of apprehension
because we don't want to go backwards
but at the same time putting up the
basketball rooms today is perfect for us
back out live the city of las vegas has
had their basketball rims up for some
time now
in addition to getting other courts up
and running the governor's directive is
also allowing
full contact sports to resume practice
as well as tournaments
and games reporting live tonight from
craig ranch regional park kate houston 8
news now
kate thank you